the southern nevada health district is  expanding they've recently opened a new  facility at bonanza and  wardell in the east valley dr fermin  leguin tells us the space will offer  vaccinations and clinical services to  both kids and adults who lack access to  proper medical care  there are many people who have no  insurance or limited access to to  insurance with well  by having those centers there we  actually  are making sure that at least they have  a place to go where they receive the  appropriate medical services  well plans are also underway for a third  location on fremont street this is  happening in the spring